i get it
you get over it okay
please believe me
before you know it you forget all about
it
go
[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'll be doing a
preview for the 11th episode of better
call saul's final season i still love
the idea that i don't really know what
will happen next but there is a short
teaser and some tasty clues to discuss
there's also some promo photos a
confirmed title and synopsis and some
interesting implications from the
timeline revelations that popped up
during nippy if any of that sounds like
spoilers to you then this is your chance
to leave and with that out of the way
let's get into it the big breaking news
yesterday was that episode 11 is titled
breaking bad this popped up on some of
the streaming services and the episodes
writer and director tom snozz confirmed
this to be true on twitter this mirrors
saul goodman's first appearance in
episode 8 of the original show's second
season having the title better call saul
we've already visited the breaking bad
timeline in episode 9 but we still
haven't had those much teased scenes
with walter white and jesse pinkman the
episode description sounds like it could
be about them it reads the partners
escalate their enterprise to new levels
but the one from episode 10 also sounded
like it could be them and i'm sure you
recall that there were no scenes just a
mention however i do think we'll see
brian cranston at the very least and the
episode that name checks his character's
journey through one of the best tv
series of all time i think we'll
probably see aaron paul as well but i
don't think anything's guaranteed
because it's just sort of been like that
part of the reason i'm not sure how long
we'll visit the breaking bad timeline is
that all three of the promo photos that
amc released are in black and white
there are two different shots of gene
where he's in his street clothes rather
than the cinnabon getup when during the
daytime and one at night i don't notice
much to talk about other than he's
wearing different clothes in each of
these and that hints that there is more
of the gene story to come also in the
insider podcast michelle mclaren who
directed 610 said that peter gould
brought in all the directors for the
last episodes to do a sort of workshop
about shooting in black and white i
mentioned that mr snozz is directing
this one and mr gilligan is directing
the next that makes it sound like
there's a chance that there could be a
lot of omaha in our future and the final
promo photo that features jeff fits
right into that that doesn't mean we
can't jump around in time and i
mentioned this in my last video and we
talked about it a lot during the stream
everything points to the events in the
gene timeline happening in october of
2010. i don't want to get into all of
the details that support that in this
video but when i was watching the last
episode and heard gene and frank
discussing football games i wondered if
they were revealing clues about when
this was happening by the time i walked
the dogs and ran an errand the internet
sleuths had already put the pieces
together i'll try to find a post to link
in the description that contains all the
details if you're interested but what i
think is more interesting is that this
date happens between two major dates in
this universe it establishes that jimmy
has been in hiding as jean for about
seven months since he was disappeared by
ed back in march the events of 6 10 then
are a month in change after walter white
returned to albuquerque and died on
september 7th
the other important date is saul's
birthday because in the 405 flash
forward francesca agreed to take a call
on that day that's supposed to happen on
november 12th which would be just weeks
after the mall scam he pulled off with
jeff nothing has really occurred to
change my mind that kim is the most
likely person to be on the other end of
that call and if it's an annual thing
this would be the first time it's
happening after he fled his life in
albuquerque walter white's death is the
type of story that could turn into
national news if that's the case that
could account for some of the paranoia
we watched gene struggle with during the
scenes that led to him getting picked up
by jeff's taxi at the end of season 4.
could also mean that kim could have
heard something about this something
about saul being wanted and she might be
worried about him wherever it is that
she settled after she left does any of
that change anything or make a reunion
more likely after this call i guess that
depends on what's going on in kim's life
more than anything else either way given
the timing this call seems like it'll be
an important plot point in the next
couple of episodes another thing that
might be important or maybe not at all
is the 611 teaser they aired this mid
credits in the last episode which is a
slightly different approach i wonder if
they placed it there because the one
from 609 wasn't included in the stream
on amc plus it continues with the
mysterious teaser trend we've had going
on since the mid-season break and that
means that it's pretty hard to say much
about it it is a black and white aerial
shot that shows a car pulling up to a
crossroads the captions for the voice
over say it's soul talking which is a
little weird considering black and white
equals gene that's just something to
think about though because
mysteriousness is the point of these but
in an episode where we may jump back in
time this could be from the salt period
of his life and that would mean he could
be talking to anyone including walter
white or jesse pinkman he chuckles and
says i get it you get over it okay
please believe me before you know it
you'll forget all about it go my initial
take when this aired right after the
episode would be that it's related to
kim it's probably due to the question of
what happens to her always being on my
mind and the way this sounds like the
conversation they had in the hotel in a
way that makes it a little less likely
he's saying it to her since it's a
conversation they already had but the
show does like to echo itself when it
makes sense there's also the question of
whether this dialogue will even be a
part of 611. there was a lot of
speculation about the happy ending line
during the mid-season break and that
turned out to be gene talking about a
made-up dog to carol burnett several
episodes after the teaser was released
the thing that makes me think this is
from the next episode is because that's
how it was in the last two teasers they
released after the episodes we had saul
parroting mike saying one day we'll
realize we hadn't thought about it at
all and jeans rhyme from the robbery
after 609. visually the shock conjures
thoughts of omaha more than anywhere
else and a crossroads always makes you
think about a decision that has to be
made which way to go next this is a
question that could be related to what
gene does next things that saul might be
considering in the breaking bad timeline
or the bit of jimmy mcgill that's still
buried in there somewhere at any time he
might decide to make an appearance i
wouldn't mind seeing each of these
versions of the character having to make
that kind of decision and the upcoming
episode i think it would most likely be
about what jean's up to but i guess you
could also ask this question about kim
if she does end up being involved in
this episode which i hope she does i
think with nippy showing us that we're
not going to be spending
most of the time in the breaking bad
timeline certainly makes it seem more
likely that we will get something about
what kim's up to especially if we're
heading towards them coming back
together
for gene i think the final shot of him
in the last episode is somewhat
ambiguous his spirits are lifted after
the scam and he has his moment looking
at the store that reads as him being
satisfied with what he accomplished was
this taste of the action something he
can walk away from or is it just a thing
that will set this cycle back in motion
it's hard to say it's also hard to
imagine jeff being involved in the
episode if there isn't a problem or if
gene just has another scam he needs him
for then it's hard to imagine that not
leading to a problem of its own the way
things were left gene was kind of in a
good position but considering there's
three full episodes to go you can't
imagine that that will last i still like
the idea of marion being more than she
let on the most i saw a few theories
that imagined her being a do-gooder that
would turn saul in but that kind of
feels like a waste of carol burnett's
talents to me i'm also not a big fan of
her secretly being related to or
connected to one of the other major
characters in the story perhaps there's
something about jeff's time in
albuquerque maybe she was there as well
but i think it's important to remember
that jeff came in contact with jean by
chance he was just the cab driver who
picked him up at the hospital i suppose
you could go back and come up with a way
that that was all staged but i don't
think that's what's happening i would
love to see her turn on jean and become
a worthy adversary who's trying to use
him for something that she needs rather
than trying to take him down he did pull
a move on jeffy who she seems to be
protective of though so if we're going
to be hanging around in omaha i can't
imagine we've seen the last of her i
mean the introduction to the character
was that she still likes to handle
things herself then jean concocted a
situation where she needed his help so
that he could work his way into her life
he seemed to win her over with his charm
but she could have been playing along to
try to figure out what kind of game he
was actually playing most of these
suspicions come from their last
interaction the mention of albuquerque
gene getting tripped up on the nippy
question and her insistence that he was
a good influence on jeff it's funny
because in the last episode description
he was the new player in the game so the
partners escalating their new enterprise
to new levels could be him and gene the
reason why they would come back together
is the big question though i don't know
the answer to that i can't wait to see
what they had in mind and i think that's
a good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think about
this teaser what you think about staying
in the gene timeline and do you think
that we'll finally get our walton jesse
scenes in the episode that's called
breaking bad it seems like it should be
a done deal but it also seems like
they're having a little bit of fun
playing with us if you want to talk more
about what might happen next join us for
the live stream this saturday we'll be
talking about theories and predictions
and answering all your questions please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon